the comedy sir would like you to know
that the views and opinions expressed on
this podcast are strictly those of the
speakers or authors and do not
necessarily reflect or represent the
views and opinions held by the Comedy
Store and its affiliates
[Music]
what we were taught we were just talking
i jus said you showcase in 98 wow I was
telling her that I'm coming to was up
sounds new lukewarm world hot again and
I was hot again you get was only one but
Studios to the those the whole time we
were here too you were in that video um
when I'm Joe Rogan economist oh yeah
you're in the last video imitating argot
helmet on yeah that was like angry
around here somewhere people always like
uh so I watched that Joe Rogan video and
like yeah I know look Y at the end let
me see I'm like yeah I got it and the
great part about it is that it's a video
of Joe Rogan confronting Carlos Mencia
about stealing jokes and then the video
closes with your healing target heritage
action
just straight stealing his act perfect
what are you gonna do that's how it is I
was think you know like Oh like cuz I
live in a valley now and I'm coming out
ugly in earthquakes and then now [ __ ]
Northridge earthquake with 94 yeah I was
I went home that night I will do in the
pot look yeah
here at the Comedy Store income of it
comical doctor was his dog the tar that
the yeah well that's why do you remember
bark dogs yeah of course no one ever
remembers barn I was sitting there in a
creepy the Todd yeah working with just
sweat sorry and binge t-shirts I had no
underwear yeah and I'm - was sitting
next to me she said she's kind of
[ __ ] happen when mixing my hair just
being the [ __ ] dog yeah it's so true
so is this pre Todd having a full
breakdown yeah he had just creepy
he had like a lobotomy so yeah he lost
it ready madam when I only do [ __ ] when
clearly in some way Todd yeah my
introduction was his mom showing up here
and being like my son Todd is lost
I'm taking like a little kid and then
someone's like yeah that guy's he's old
am i quiet in there
yeah he's that guy in the head shot with
Robin Williams I'm like wait why is his
bomb here then he's like 30-something a
huge producer she works with Laverne
what's her name Lenny uh Penny Marshall
oh yeah I said Lenny Marshall I'm an
idiot
Lenny Marshall
but then that dude shut up in the night
he was he's completely crazy I went to
turn the lights off in the backstage in
the main room and I when I turn the
lights on to switch off the fuses he was
just standing in the dark in the corner
staring at the corner frightening I was
like [ __ ] but I guess he escaped
Don Barris yeah he was hanging with
dombarris and then wandered off wait I
have a question because I was here
during the Northridge earthquake and
comedy store yes and I was Carlos was on
stage Mencia and I was like [ __ ] em it's
used to make us stay until the comic got
off and he was on told like 3:30 and
then I went home and his [ __ ]
half-hour was on HBO and I was like this
[ __ ]
I can't escape and then that happen and
I woke up like it's because I was kind
of still new out of Philly I woke up
like swinging a bat thinking somebody
was breaking in and that was the worst
scariest [ __ ] thing and I blame
Carlos for that earthquake as well
damaged it well you know he ruined at
6.00 there did you ever work with him no
I never I never worked with him at all
you're not only when you were lucky one
only when he hosted some show for Jeff
ball des Eaux back in the days and I he
was a host yeah I never really like open
for him or had to follow him but only
the laughs after he did like two hours
oh she just takes the ten o'clock show
story late of course that's how we
really work together classic move on his
part
no that's what because he would do a lot
of those Latino whatever festivals
Assent it but Valdez remember when Joe
Diaz mom beat him out at Maryland my
Maryland
although Mario the first time I read
like I saw him like do arm it was 1996
and we were doing the Latino laughter
Tabo and San Antonio mm-hmm Freddy Sodor
myself and
harder Holtzman on that one yes I get to
the story could wait Heron Carter was in
the Latino yeah and Brian Holtzman ok
because just about did liked him and so
column and SIA wasn't supposed to do the
Latino laughter to be laughable because
it was Showtime and had an HBO deal so
he couldn't be a part of it but he
decided to fly himself over there and
still crash the show and what a [ __ ]
after Freddy's photos are no I got off
the stage then Johnny Sanchez got off
then now they were like changing the
kiss the batteries for the camera or
something or the film mmm and even see
it does a gets it and right after for
Soto and um they're trying get off you
know like what we're doing or taping a
show here so he does his clog said and
then I'm after that Brian hoes meant to
follow him but you know where I never
told us that I mean he told me yeah
happen he had to follow him so the crowd
was like already beat up you know there
is done and then Brian Holtzman opens up
with um this is not a comedy show I
brought on immigration is a bust
there's also so every first letter back
to Mexico oh my god do the would the
King is that he was talking about leaf
blowers and ships were stereotypical
[ __ ] magic I got to it alum film I did
every every story of ever not been film
holds been doing any show outside of LA
it's always the worst and here his mom
with him that we have his mom human
hitman and momma got to hang out with
him his mom we know what third-wheeling
we're riding a boat together yes they
threw him in he should hear it through a
bit about who got my mom's I hear man
she got arrested for spitting [ __ ] a
souvenir from the Alamo also to take
back the Alamo
oh man that was tough on him that said
he made it he made it on his I don't
know what nothing else to do so he just
you know make the comedian laugh yeah
yeah because it's Freddie and Johnny I
mean they
came running back to report that I mean
Freddie I think they'll be there
screaming laughing repairs I don't know
what's going on I was new
yes accepting it they okay this how
Comedy Works then yeah people popping
how long do you think Carlos did I think
a half an hour 35 minutes but we're all
doing 70 it was like a short like you're
filming so Comedy Central kind of
presents thing like shoulders ends like
that yeah [ __ ] and I forgot Darren
Carter was such a big state kind of a
staple he would do a lot of Latino wrong
everyone hit the beat box and the Snoop
Dogg I saw a tractor when I first met
him the key bro I thought he was mate
me too they brought him up this guy's
gonna be on show tenant whoa show time
he would be huge then I'm gonna same
plane with him we're going gonna do a
show time show me too okay not as
impressive wait wait we're on this
you're still the Red Rooster back then
yeah I'll a shady side shady side what
year did you start doing comedy um I
started like at night I started like off
and on like either a little bit of 93 a
little bit 94 quit for a year we had a
baby oh I came back in November of 95
then I got a TV credit 96 with the let
you know that can fall dead hook me up
you know like I was thinking I've never
been trained so he put on every show
every single show he did well yeah if
you're not going to complain about
Carlos coming in or don't complain about
how most people get paid oh we're not
good I was just happy you know like a
little kid I'll just get like whatever
all right I'll go with you guys yeah
that's how I ended up on tour with Pauly
Shore just like this is cool how
everybody and then after a while you're
like I don't think this is as cool as I
thought it was I think this is right
this can't be leave why am I going back
to Tampa again you were City Haiti Bor
yeah that's for [ __ ] well is that
where Paulie goes that there's an improv
in Ybor City that's hilarious
and it's good they got the most strip
clubs per capita here dude
I've never been to a strip club what yes
to this day every strip club we've ever
been to us with folly well that's an
until they're like dude Paul you can
come in but you know after last time you
got to keep your pants on this time good
yeah it's like a lean of arm strip board
on eboard Street okay and there's one
place which I said is good like a planet
or a spaceship I think oh yeah yeah and
if you go to the things like VIP the top
of the spaceship inside the strip bar
hmm because fluffy you got I would went
on top Gabriel glanced yes oh yeah sure
I made it to the top of though he got
off a shimmy I was in the bottom you
know yeah I always had to stand with the
manager and talk to that guy well that
sucks
all the babes talk eyelid I saw the only
one a bit day you know when the big
superstar though they're hanging out
with everybody and I got to hang around
with all the other people at the manager
yeah look at them laughs amen yeah
that's always me I won't ever be here -
I was in the kitchen I don't know why
maybe I don't know yeah I feel more
empowered always had it on the girls are
come on bi hey you wanna dance I don't
have any money just looking like goodbye
then I gotta sell you is probably pretty
cool man if you like the movies okay no
not really
yeah did you and Gabriel do a show
together
yeah I'm Gabriel glasses and I we're um
I met him money when he first one is one
to do stand-up comedy because I had that
room in Montebello yeah wile coyote
scorpion and he comes in shy sits to the
side and he brings it dug his cholo this
gangster
Mexican gangster was tattooed on his
head all over the body and he was talk
to me like talk you know what's up man
and I'm from the hood - man was - what's
up I thought it's gonna be a fight yeah
what's up what's up got my friend over
the want to do comedy and by this time I
was like why don't you tell your friend
to come over here man had to bring his
messenger hey cut it out shy I want to
do stand-up and I say you're next row
hell yeah
he went up on stage and he did well
he killed he's been killing ever since
and um I got him his first road trip
cake you really are responsible for him
because he used to do an imitate
of you but it was slimy huh yeah and in
first special yeah [ __ ] amazing I
mean I his first special was his dirty
many half-hour special was set up
perfectly by Comedy Central
yeah because he put they flew me out so
I got to be his warm up before he went
up to layer by that time the audience in
the air he knew you know who I was so
when you see the reference day my friend
Philippe who just saw so then everybody
yeah everybody tell you what I was
everybody thought I was missile so they
know to this day when I tell them I'm
the guy he talks about oh you are real
yeah I'm a real person I was fired from
the gigs in 2004 oh [ __ ] yeah I turn
into a diva everybody does hey I wanna
be a diva on someone else's show then be
a diva with my show okay
that's a good way to look at it yeah I
just I just try and always stay diva you
got always pure diva record yeah managed
to make sure I never get anywhere in
this town big attitude little response
that's what it's all about I dunno what
helped me like in the beginning not to
be like sad or worried about where I'm
going in this career you know yeah but I
miss those times you know when you don't
know what's gonna happen ten years from
now
oh so you're performing every night and
I'm getting married and get high having
fun so I was glad that up a lot of
people did help me you know like
together them like Paul Rodriguez took
me Paul yeah member George Russell
Peters um Gabriel Iglesias yeah you are
in a half-hour
whoo did you ever do I have motion on
the bill you have an hour comes an hour
on on Showtime for sat Montoya yeah
that was a long time ago yeah I was in
2012 it happened so fast
yeah I was talking to Alex Reymundo he
was management God yeah and we were
doing a show in DC and he was yeah I
want to do one hour special but I don't
know how to do it because well if you
want to do it I'll talk to Scott and the
next day he called me well Philippe went
to our special in two weeks I didn't
have time to prepare
or no see that's my toy for ya come on
man I got the venue before they get out
- we [ __ ] it man the material that I
did was all my job that I've been doing
for the last 15 years I should have
called it like Sanford I'm telling you
for the last time but all my YouTube
stuff it's on a special you know I don't
know I don't have time to write chorus I
just did what I knew two weeks two weeks
two weeks with you know somebody you
think it's like looking out for you
they taped three specials that day
course I was last the first one with
Bobcat go away
and the second one forgot his name and
the 31 with me nice see how you forgot
that person's name there nobody paw like
me because part of vegans he came to
visit us in El Paso hmm and we know
every time Paul og will show up to the
Laugh Factory I don't drink I don't
drink back then so I'll use my drink
ticket to give it to Paul I was a
bartender I was Paul drink that's a good
bride Irish Irish coffee all right right
make me one then I'll go over there like
I'm like um like spider from Goodfellas
here mister here here mr. Rodriguez
here's your drink sir go sit down
leave you alone so just Gilman's drink
and step away you know and and walk away
the home alone and one day he showed up
to a paso and he took us to Mexico okay
I was scared I had no green card at the
time you know I lost everything and all
that I'm I want to lie on the way back I
don't want to say no I can't go yeah
were you born here and I was going to
Mexico
yeah and we get to Mexico first of all
um it was late like one and Paul Judah
just afterwards oh he just crashed our
show you wanna have tacos do you Mexican
guys or what I was being a bit good yeah
of course but then Gabriel says
everything's closed Paul it's one
o'clock then Paul look to heaven goes
everything is closed if you only have
five dollars in your pocket
Oh took us to Mexico and we ordered an
Impala like real famous like in those
areas he's like Muhammad Ali
oh [ __ ] like caught that famous but with
a whole
people like people pointing him there no
to just point Pablo yeah they love him
so we get to Mexico
waiting tacos they were like waiting in
line to come back and they pull those
over the border pusher who we had a van
full of Mexicans right and there's a
picture of what we're all at this so
actually we got from if we lost an
American citizen over American citizen
yeah yeah we all American citizen yeah
we crossed the border we made it fine
the next day we look he takes it to a
strip bar high and he's making know how
oldest reporter taco makeup yeah fish
taco he's making out with some chick and
then which is a huge violation of the
rules I don't know why eww I run over
her and then I had some chick but then I
ride a money so you know she was done
with me up i watch again you know soccer
guard back to hanging our ladder the
manager how long you been working here
bro all a long time bro yes pollens are
having a good time uh-huh that's love
filled again I heard that it's not make
it mean you're getting fish balls right
here so pause taking off and then um
he's gonna buzz man so I have a head of
Viagra I've been saving for like a month
nice for a good occasion for me sure and
I say you know what are you I would like
30 damn no but but I all you know just
one yeah I already know the older it is
easy don't worry
all right yeah all right how's water
pocket gives you try area so I say you
know what Paul here you go man so I'll
get a porridge big and go thank you
because you need it more than me so I
give it to him when we're in the car
with the stripper
Gabriel Iglesias and the strip was young
she was old man my mom's a big fan of
you Paul she's watching a Pablo and she
saw the Kings accompany his age was
coming out um you know and then Paula
Jesus tells Gabriel um I heard you been
imitating me now
what you um yeah okay man
talk to her mom for me and for the girl
called her mom on the phone so Gabriel
is I'm
imitating Paula gee you know
consequently walk how I'm making out
with that chicken Larry does he do a
good Paul Roger I know he does good in
imitation it was a good part
impression impression yeah yeah are you
saying I wait that's right I think
that's right yeah I don't know how he
does Papa Paul we start off with a huge
word distance intentions is like
consequently you know and what happened
over there and for depression that
sounds like a black eyes of pressure why
I work at a bank
Casey Casey that's like a Rix radio
voice sometimes we do like a little
radio
talk dates in the airport when the plane
he goes man my date was hard like ties
in a South Point to me you my man will
never go hungry in this business I love
that so after that he took me along it's
like everywhere you know gambling he
took it a read oh oh yeah I don't be
anywhere okay I get it
Kenneth told me with my first time
flying oh [ __ ] yeah really
I never been anywhere and my first time
in Reno he's like Kazmir what does it
worry things about you complaining about
your room
I'm not completed by my room I'm not
complaining you know just got here you
will when you see my room where were a
silver legacy no legs and that's a
killer man by you sweets
oh nice did you guys do the big room the
big room yeah that's a kids'll a
factories in there now
yeah the little comedy club is in the
silver legs there's another one -
underground cafe
underground comedy oh yeah a couple of
my friends were doing that one I was at
the Laugh Factory and then there's also
the Improv in Tahoe but I want I
actually
I stayed at the Silver Legacy in Reno on
time I drove up there my college oh I'm
gonna say for fun [ __ ]
well yeah my college was in a basketball
tournament my family was out there so I
drove up to go there and I won like 600
bucks on slots she got robbed
no I'm just so shocked I was like 23 or
24 and I put in you know five dollars
whatever and I played for like two
minute
at one and ice - tell Don I don't
understand what the winning is sometimes
like I just did the 20 lines or whatever
it is oh yeah I hold it
oh yeah like I don't you bet versus what
you get it wasn't like there was like
three cherries across or something I
obviously want on some other cross
pattern but it just kept bringing and
then it just made noise like there was
change coming out yeah and then they
came over and they're like uh we need to
see your ID and like okay
I gave her my yesterday Soyoung he looks
a little boy
it was great either one six on our box
I'm like I'm so glad I can met my family
and RINO this did not see thunder but
yeah I was $50 to stay in Reno Reno is
cheap man you could have fun in Reno
there's a little creepy spots you know
junky filthy that what was that um
reality show not reality skit Reno 911
do it I was live watched that I was like
oh this is so cute then I went to Reno
I'm like oh [ __ ] this is a documentary
is how bad it is it's bad when it when I
was I'm working at that place my first
time there I didn't know there was a
river yeah let me not know that so I
just saw this blonde girl walking at
like 11:10 in the morning with just a
bathing suit
yeah well I know beautiful and she was
wearing sandals and I was like following
like to a block behind her right off a
block behind her like I know was she
glowing man like she were nice pretty
early yeah [ __ ] is legal here I might as
well follow her oh yeah Rico yeah Linum
she disappeared over there by Circus
Circus I went back to my room then I was
telling people through the bathing suit
man Oh bro there's a [ __ ] river over
there
she probably got dumped or something
yeah Bridget yeah they have the tubing
every day they were tooling there it's
frightening people dogs are you know
you're doing the backstroke and you're
hitting a pitbull meth-heads people
those people don't even have to beings
like real tools yeah it's like white
trash yeah
I don't know no no browser I know that
Mexican we know how to rap rap in a
whole life and you're usually in fully
dressed full address [ __ ] I saw a
vision the redneck family for Mama
Papa and two kids on the one of the
inflatable beds yeah be portable said
I'm taste that bad and we know that he's
right now that's beautiful
they're so weird and most of them are
homeless - there's a lot of homeless
young white homeless yeah it's a dog
just running around like pimples like
the [ __ ] do these guys have pimples for
yeah I live a string no leash just a
string yeah they are me I worry about
the leash you don't you don't care if
that dog runs away forever now you gotta
give it a chance
[ __ ] yeah I was in needle life I did
that improv in South Lake Tahoe and one
of the other comics I was performing
with was like hey we should go to Reno
do something why don't we do that I'm
not going to do that Tahoe yeah he was
like well I don't have a car like I
don't see how this is my problem I do
have a car Natalie banking wealth Lake
Tahoe I was with a [ __ ] I can't remember
the dude's name it was how he's a normal
guy then I can't remember the head
lighter kind of a blind blind ish black
guy blind ish black is hilarious maybe
wonder guy I wish humanity he was funny
- I can't remember his name though but
not charlie Cozart know I just know he's
legally blind just used to wear glasses
like you remember Charlie Cozart like I
used to wear on sunglasses all the time
now this dude hid
thick glasses he was really he had been
punched in the face or something that he
didn't do anything about it
and everyone's like you need to go get
that check and he was like on you know
I'm a band so I didn't do anything
committee [ __ ] he went blind in the eye
oh [ __ ] yeah that's one hell of a punch
yeah and now I know he tours a lot in
Canada cos he kept telling me about no
no I think he moved up there because he
gets more comedy work but oh man go they
like blind black guys out there that's
Canada like they are
there's no idea can't see any of this
maple syrup come on up here
so that oh man to perform here and close
out the show Robert William area
yeah people be begging us to get him on
the podcast but he's not weird we're you
know this smell is hard though yeah
thank you were letting napkins right
yeah paper blah plastic Ralph and we
have plastic Ralph's bags to protect him
from something the First Amendment
shield or something I remember when he
went up late and the dice man was there
and together the dingdong show Dom
Barrett
Dom Barrett and I guess the Todd was
sitting somewhere oh yeah him as Dom
Berenson the Todd you still yeah so
these guys I guess they know him
personally and I was just me and Gabriel
we're watching the show and he goes up
and they start blocking his way to get
out they are putting chairs all over the
place fermenting yeah they're saying a
word to him the only happy that they
know they go we go big up or something I
don't know I was I don't know what it
was but they kept saying [ __ ] buttons
he bunny yeah yeah but they can say
buttons buttons in Inadi although I
didn't got it with button but my he was
freaky now he don't know was also
bathroom yeah yeah I know here to hurdle
yeah yeah and I thought I would and I
was like I've been bullied right on this
is pretty much bullying right now it's
giant yelling yeah but yeah I can when I
showed up I didn't I just didn't
understand at first one what the [ __ ] is
going on why is everyone [ __ ] about
this guy and so then I just went sat in
the front row and just laughed at
everything he did then he just kept
getting this real creepy giant smile
like he's finally connecting with
someone and then Don came up to me he's
like I keep it up he loves that is I'm
like alright and so I keep smiling
that's a great joke next thing you know
Don Barris has picked me up over his
head throwing me at Robert and I'm
flying to they're just like well this
dude is strong as [ __ ] and then I
provides Eric oh so sorry that the Nazis
are attacking you because you're a
phantom on Emily yeah it's not really
call them Eric no matter
how many times I told them that was my
name in deco all right Erica I'll make
sure I call you that he lies we though
that guy's lovely
I was smoking with your Z and then yours
he left like a half a blonde right there
laying there and he called him and after
we left he came back got it yeah
usually if you give it to him he won't
take no no no no I love the tank gift so
find it that's different like Mickey
used to give a bus money back and forth
to the store because she felt bad for
him yeah so he always got a little
envelope that he was allowed to take
from here because it was considered hey
yeah because he was going on he was he
would take weed from me that was the
only thing well maybe I'm a ride ones
still can't get that out of my alley
that smell staying 94 seriously I give a
little canister it would have like two
buds in it but it was like good weed and
then I've got hey Robert this is extra
if you want very much and I really tried
to give him a jacket one time and it was
like we were [ __ ] setting them up
yeah because that's about the button
thing that goes back to the buttons
there's a whole thing nah embarrass
we'll bring a case of buttons in and
shake it and he would lose his [ __ ]
mind
like oh my god I don't know what the
buttons represent but I was just a
waiter back then so I felt bad for him
so I would like talk to him all the time
so he loved me who watch my stand-up now
and he's like he'll give me tags also
Hey look look what year did you show
Casey reset 1998 I think oh my and you
showcase permittee
yeah I had um I think I think it was
Johnny Sanchez who put in a good word
for me yeah and um and when I was
showcasing for her it was Mary Martinez
sitting next to her mark
and now Cheryl Sheppard sitting on the
other side to keep guden and cooled it
away from her and lemare when heads yes
an Asian guy here change in [ __ ]
everybody how come how come Alice's
hungry
hungry dude this guy ah I always been
cool people you know if they're funny
like if I know somebody booked in a show
like people like Chad I'll just give all
my show just to like you know I will be
cool and I could just tell you know did
something for that guy and I'm but Peter
man he'd freeze every show he ever
booked over he freaked everybody out
yeah I believe you put him what if you
are like the nicest he would be like him
out
I [ __ ] hate Peter Channel I saw
hidden item right human Gould and we're
by the droves this blows right here you
know G [ __ ] I don't suck dick for spots
you don't have to suck a dick it's a
clip you've got the wrong thing yeah no
he's oh dude I'm be or Esquivel I guess
told me you know agent Diana knows a guy
named Peter channel him a bogus timing
they do it for 200 bro go do a $50 that
burrito so I get together too
so the over desk about performing on
stage Peter Chan is rolling around all
the tables getting everybody aluminum
cans now is it like you will take like
you feeling with that coke because it
the coke and every time our Gilbert us
will learn applause break you smashed a
can so it's always last week and then
finally Gilbert said young Peter you
need more money bro and from the stage
oh no very good I'm going on good is the
word what a piece of [ __ ] and then yeah
the wild coyotes the the waitress they
were put let you know the leftover from
everybody in that little cart the food
car that's a yeah Peter was going up
next and you were studying into the food
court just eating all the leftovers in
Manila whatever it was just appointed
poisoning that's all good more more how
come how come there's always the food
leftover for the Asian guy by ha shut up
Peter computer man yeah he would get
miss easier yeah when people were
showcasing and it was annoying like
Freddie used to Freddy Soto used to try
to block them and they used to fight all
the time like Missy would offer Franny
on some popcorn and Peter would come out
of nowhere I doesn't pop on michey and
Frederick come on gotta hear like oh
it's awful Freddy and I hate it is the
last time
I saw was when she ate those weed
brownies that wheels made and wheels
brought them up he's like yeah this
Penta Penta table of them so so Macedo
we're all [ __ ] stoner so you know we
just feel good need to walk up all their
[ __ ] brownies yeah man and then no
one said anything till we need to start
to eating them and then about 20-30
minutes ladies I [ __ ] up I don't know
what happened I don't know I cannot
drive well just get in your car because
yeah we don't want to [ __ ] listen to
you I think I think somebody tried to
give me babe no one tried to have didn't
get roofied idiot so it depends okay for
like nine weeks straight
oh [ __ ] I know Scott day they made you
come back every week yeah yeah with
Scott in 98 right Corian take over no
bald guy right no Scott was involved
here like light hair um Paul doing do
you probably know not 98 oh yeah it's
true
yeah so the guy named Duncan working out
yeah but not that was one hour Duncan
trust another dunk a minute yeah Brandon
Brandon Duncan II yeah he was the
manager yeah oh wow okay yeah I was like
wait Duncan Brandon Duncan was our
manager I audition with the same night
that um some guy got passed to the main
room immediately
Oh black comedian his first spot was in
the maintenance yeah I mean yes [ __ ] I
was in junior high schools no media yeah
I was like everybody was like all [ __ ]
put him in the main no I would like my
hat and then I thought I remember I
would work in a door and I didn't know
anybody I was wearing the white comedy
stone t-shirt yeah I wasn't good enough
for the black tee a white one yeah
and I wish I stopped him and I said
excuse me um legally either spy the main
room man I sell red men going in so I
guess I'm you yelled at me you were
regular directly good now you have a bad
attitude you must be here robably a
comic here yeah yeah I didn't I never
really like I think my I got a main room
spot two weeks after I got passed yeah
this was I remember it was like same
night or yeah weird like that like it
was so immediate I can't think of it
wasn't AJ Jamal and I know it's ticklish
yeah he's a host or laughs back John
suddenly - yeah and he would but he was
so good in a room he was my favorite act
to watch when I first started here in
the main room but he was already past
early on that comedian had a bit with
music I remember of course it was summer
lovin happened so bad and he's doing
like the grease thing with the music and
just turned to my me I don't think it
does that bit anymore so I hope not he
might I hope it was Sergio love I know
he's got a great Dido bit [ __ ] you Josh
what's the other one that Sergio does
that sticks in my [ __ ] head all the
time I hate it it's a wrap one in my
convertible West Side Calcutta
[ __ ] any Matsuda CJ yeah
no Simon I would okay him ago hmm
interesting interesting how could I make
that Latino yeah because he wasn't get
white work they weren't letting the
ginger in they were like no he's weird
Mexicans are like a year go that's
old-school of treated like an Irishman
he had with minorities oh man
he was like he was even shy that guy I'm
Darren Carter
nothing yeah yeah we're a bar we're
doing the show with Rudy Marino and
community and um we're seeing at the bar
I don't drink
and I'm trying to pick up on his girl
and we're talking and um I'm laying man
I'm in but then I'm I go to the center
and I come back and that girls crying
sitting next to Derek or no the party
starter man what happened man oh man
which are talking about parents and she
told me she don't have a dad that's what
I never made my dad and get that into it
[ __ ] hey talk about [ __ ] block a [ __ ]
block but he'll run away father
yeah he's dead I don't have a father
right yeah that's the easiest one get
laid by as long as no one sucking
Felipe's dick tonight I think we'll get
through the night you [ __ ]
I have a father he's a mental patient
but he's fun we did a one-nighter and
I'm Arizona
I would like 100 degrees outside
although outside a big rap show I'm
doing 15 minutes Derek are doing 15 and
it was like we were sweating and the
promoters friend goes you guys want to
go hang out I know a cool spot I don't
know if him Darren carding him spoke
privately and they said we're taking
where you want to go Philippe and I said
all right you know I don't smoke weed
back there and do nothing if I'll go
keep in mind Eric Carter went to go get
changed and he put on these read Richard
Simmons shorts you know they come with a
liner inside and a little underwear
inside here so my grounding George yes
the pockets on the side there where you
get little track shoes of Cheryl we're
we're going we're going to work out of
what the guy takes us to a swingers bar
it cost 35 bucks to get in it's called
encounters in Arizona just like three
swingers bars in Phoenix Arizona took it
to that one 35 bucks to get in three
dudes coming in paying 35 bucks to get
in and white legs is out yes know why we
get there and this is ugly ass lady who
look like I'm honey Boo Boo's mom a real
beauty was short short right a [ __ ]
very yeah honey Boo Boo's mom she's
wearing just a nightgown and I'm she's
in charge of the little buffet they have
there
who the hell like neither know a lot you
might as well get some snacks
nachos cheese nips chicken nuggets you
know and what a big beam this is and she
she's hooking it up and she the only
child like you the only woman here go to
the side they're like three by three
truck drivers having sex with a 42 year
old woman or a 45 year old woman her and
she's blowing all of them in the jacuzzi
say like man my future means their
encourages watching it eating right in
front of them eating snacks like this
however what it is up hedonist and his
legs like crossed his white land whose
bums yeah hail to me yeah we need cheese
man watching the Oregon orgy right here
going on in front of us the Phoenix is
weird because I was there with Paulie
and Ari Shaffir that's and we were
hanging out wouldn't that improv and
Tempe that guy Dan was in charge Wow
he's a beast
yeah so we're hanging out with him a
couple nights in a row and he's just
being creepy as [ __ ] he's all choked up
and weird until we meet these girls and
and it's like I think one of them
invited us to a party and we went to the
party it was like uh what's the college
there Arizona state Arizona parties a
bunch of college kids and I'm like 24 so
I'm kind of close snakes these people
always like 30-something and the cops
show up like 10 minutes after we get to
the party and everyone's freaking out
not always like well maybe I'll just go
talk to the cops he's like yeah man
you're 30 I'll go talk to you so re goes
and talks to the cops and the cops just
leave and then it's just like us and
like probably five chicks and like two
or three other dudes that are standing
there I guess whatever and so we hung
out we played beer pong first time I
played beer pong and then we left
because we had to take the Pauly Shores
dead wagon back to the hotel okay so
then the next night one of the girls
called Ari and said hey you know we're
going to meet this club or whatever more
like all right so we go that club that
Dan guy takes us
like hey we're getting on this this bus
party bus and we're like okay that's
cool
the only thing is can't bring the creepy
old dude talk about Dan oh oh that
Arielle's exam sorry like oh man shouts
you don't have to tell well why do I
have to tell you you're the old guy you
got to go tell all right I'll talk to
him
sorry just go it's just like what come
with us does it what why man I brought
you here but LA so somehow he convinces
them we just can't come and so I
remember getting on this party bus me
and our n these girls when we look out
the window they're just standing there
staring at the bus like these
[ __ ] it so we start driving
around we're driving like 30 minutes
you know they're Brinks on the bus
whatever and then we just they just pull
up to some house in the Scottsdale Hills
and then they're like it's kind of like
a swinger thing don't remember me look
like we walk in this house we're like
looking around there's just people
hooking up [ __ ] [ __ ] everywhere like
this groups of above it okay they're
paired and Felipe sitting there eating
they're not just this [ __ ] there's a
creepy like John Waters looking do like
sit about that super skinny at the bars
like can I get you guys drank sighs
rumbling dad I'm not drinking this dad's
making and I'll be getting [ __ ] by the
pool easily I'm good walk out back
there's like flames shooting out of
[ __ ] up like gas [ __ ] tanks next to
pool yeah we hang out for like 20
minutes I'm like I think we gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here
I wish I was free enough to drink what
the bartender was makin and just have
sex by the way I don't get too nervous
and who's watching I'm doing this wrong
I'm sure I'm not doing this I call my
mother
I have no little game I just do for sure
the only way I was getting laid was if
that job modders guy was [ __ ] me while
I was passed out but none of the chicks
they were making up even looking at
goddamnit Oh again oh look who's awake
goddamnit I just got bill cosby'd [ __ ]
using them we cry baby
you remind me of pecker damn it
you guys never go on party at that house
there likes to go in Burbank
oh no but I feel like I heard about that
from the typical comedy to be a diet it
was a swinger thing yeah but no they
don't swing do when I was there Oh
different just party need to be a guy
that activity to walk around Heathrow
like Sam Kinison around here
no Bobcat goalie actually not any short
bald guy and he used the community the
colonies for I'll do the comedian if you
just like a hanger I hang around yeah he
had uh he had some not Johnny Hollywood
I don't know about he don't except he's
on his hat Johnny Johnny that's the one
with the odd jobs you know I was a stage
manager for every famous band and our
comic could ever live for 40 years each
person how old are you Richard Pryor
told me I was his favorite white person
Ellie uh-huh you didn't tell you that
you had like something we're like I I'm
the one to do that oh yeah
every comic you know for Carlos I'm like
you shouldn't say that yeah I will still
be buying material and you're not paying
attention
yeah I was I was here one night Freddie
lock I were hanging out and Johnny's app
started telling us about we were making
fun of him hey Johnny remember we needed
this remember we did that would just be
like the most ridiculous thing ever
remember when you told the Beatles they
should fire Peter best and hire Ringo
Starr so then Freddy goes uh he's like
Johnny you remember when when you told
Jimmy Hendrix to play the star-spangled
banner he's like I get you guys are
making fun of me but the truth is I was
the guy who told him to light his guitar
on fire like is that the truth Johnny is
that really the truth I [ __ ] Janis
Joplin that a free dog night concert
only doesn't get cooler than you Johnny
that so he wasn't the one that would
take you to this party and no those no
the guy who I remember um to that I was
like when I was in all performing but
not coming here a lot
I was gonna cover the party when I with
the white people okay
again you're see what what's the guy's
name peanut I don't know
and always thought who passed away in
Vegas oh yeah Kady Kady yeah Katie Brad
knows another guy he just moved back to
Jersey PJ PJ well he I turned up that
guy for two nights he does the
kidnapping without her here no and I get
a cookie little guy was the name Bobby
watch TV yep did he know how he knows
although how many I had in your seat
Thomas yeah here's my favorite you were
two used to get but when I first started
here he would get banned for superchip
whatever pays off I did on stage or
something stupid that's all so he was
banned so he would change his name so I
met him as your Z than he was yo mama no
mama that's what I called him when a
head on a podcast or whenever maybe you
can tell your mama when you're yours in
the [ __ ] your season yeah he just
kept changing his name because it he
didn't want Missy today you know yeah
like if she saw it on the line up she
went bought the managers we love them we
never bothered him you know we were like
a [ __ ] yeah yeah but your mom he had a
couple different names and then I break
his balls I'm like who are you this week
when we put the line up you know [ __ ]
your seat so you a party what Davey
Wester which is only a daughter funny
mood I was parting with them I don't
know how I ended up at their house
that's right though yeah by Fairfax yes
yeah I don't wanna go yeah I've been a
part of how I ended up there
it was it was truly ugly baby the peanut
butter but it's all over my god oh my
girl freaked out and I was up for like
three nights straight okay and now I'm
Peterson Philippe I gotta go to work
what he work for the Comedy Store I'll
go with you then I waited for him right
there at a little bar outside so he got
our work Jesus and I was just going in
and out in and out doing blow in the
back coming back yeah looking at Joe
Diaz copy yeah running I knew like the
real [ __ ] I don't know just done it with
no puppet specific at the end that how
many would I need a hot hot man
I didn't know that that you're hanging
out with them no the house is bad news
yeah a lot of people but it functions
but it was definitely better we're like
they're like I'm more like Iraq okay go
you know somebody yeah I know somebody
Linda's guy who looks like that actor
Peter Green
I don't know that actor mm-hmm Peter
Green he was in um whatever he was there
he doesn't come back sir
okay I thought I thought of the actor
when he showed a bra you don't actor
yeah
not only was new Peter Green was ah
thanks though
he's complimented like how high is this
guy takes up here green I don't even
know what about that in your seat tells
me I'm at wall coyotes he goes think I
know the gig at 2:00 in the morning that
paid $60 in the valley I won [ __ ] it I'm
doing nothing from 2:00 in the morning
till morning course so we go to this
place in Burbank that's the house and
there's an alley PD outside undercover
he was like the security guard he never
went inside the house he just stood
outside the house making sure you were
invited right right we get there there's
like pinball machines are arcade you
know some house parties you know the
crazy ones where everybody just starts
peeing on your yard Jesus this guy had
bathroom stalls outside his yard
I had the walls had like a urinal thing
is higher yeah well paint on the wall so
so yeah I smell it
yes he had three of them they were all
connected to the wall with house EGP
they're hilarious and he had like
another little house private little
glory hall it was a no I don't know what
kind of nobody would have opened with
that if there's a glory hole pal and I
tell your cm alright members was a
little party baby promise me yeah you
know Hegel I mean I'm your CV Stover and
he got this little nasal spray and the
nasal spray was full of cocaine and
water
oh you know some time you do coke I get
stuck right here and you know I never
did a snort water to help the rundown
yeah this thing has like half coke and a
little bit of water so like so it just
came ready to go yeah you straighten
rain-free yeah we just we'll just
pure water cocaine coming down your
throat perfectly like smooth yeah the
guy the guy I ended up mean the owner
because Afrin people used to get
addicted to that [ __ ] to my actually
used to do cocaine used to put the Afrin
my phone had sinus problem so that's
probably what the [ __ ] you was doing yes
mixing it this [ __ ] yeah I'm glad
because I happy I think I'm hooked on
the African even without doing cocaine
for yeah they say it is addictive yeah
be careful the guys name of the house
was dug and I was like I stood there to
like the part of the last guy to leave
everybody walk tons of people were
coming in and out of that house all
[ __ ] night yeah women guys people
just hired walked up and we still do it
we did comedy there
I remember my job me I kill this one
joke wow this plate invited me like
Pinocchio we're all gonna wake up
looking like donkeys in the morning
they're on this nasal spray yet
and yet in house all locked up like
there's no Sun like a come in so it was
the ultimate party lockdown yeah we had
a ledger of everybody who's been
declared by fire they had a sign in a
line in and out and um the way you did
invited he give you points likes fake
points I guess with your too [ __ ] up
he called him dougie points his name is
Doug so I call him dougie point like if
like if you are on the way out you pick
up a couple of trash like a couple of
beer bottles put him in a bag not keep
him like Peter Chan but Dan Mahli take
the trash out for him during the party
he look at you you're a nice guy bro I'm
gonna give you some dougie points so but
so I guess if you get enough Dougie
points he called on you and invited you
to the party
personally you gonna get the text
party at midnight show up instead of
having yours he bring you so III preside
and I decided I'm not gonna ever go back
to my house so as a transfer my bill do
point to somebody else can I get Filippo
Strozzi for Xenophon out there who shows
up to my show at the ice out last year
with a photo that he took of me getting
Dougie points in my face Allah God my
hair is all [ __ ] up and I know I
didn't even ask you know like how do you
think the photo guy never saw it
he must have cameras everywhere
everywhere I'm glad I'm not a thief
because I got caught that man yeah I'm
not upset domain yet you know oh [ __ ] I
can catch me that's why PJ wasn't
invited over there a lot probably but
that's I was saying like that those
houses I heard of but they were mostly
like swing houses I never heard of
somebody doing comedy and one I would
have loved to have known Dougie party
house just cuz you know I like guys I
thought it was a thing that everybody
was going there so uh the Commons were
going there well you know yeah we
weren't invited I didn't start doing
comedy until after Freddie Pat like 2008
you know I'm a late bloomer
I was just waiting tables here for 12
years so our parties would be at crest
Oh Freddie used to live in Mitzi's house
that was behind here in Creston we had
some few parties there that were pretty
uh interesting when I was talking to
Paul [ __ ] points when I saw Rodriguez
he should do this oh my god I would
count ahead Paul hello Rams Fanny
explain to him we're working together
last week we did the show outside in
Tucson 909 last week yeah and it was
outside showed outside laughing why are
they doing shows outside in Arizona ever
do they have they have to comedians go
up and then have bands right after us
okay okay and we were like fighting the
heat and I was telling him that um you
know I did this funny meme about you is
like on away what I mean I'm a fan
no matter you gotta give me podcast you
know that's the thing you know people
love hearing stories you have you as a
comedy star guy from tell me to babysit
our sorcerer and he came in after the
strike yes I don't know I think he was
part of it but he wasn't no I read the
book by the way
oh yeah Rick's in the TV show on
graduation blender scene come on Lee I
just play a random comic my presentation
thanks Peyton hell yeah my fart is very
tiny I'm just a guy on stage in the
background all the main characters are
bitching probably about how I'm on stage
they're not yeah it's good have you
watched the show yeah I saw the preview
when I thought we had a regresar on the
pocket when I saw him with a white hat
and the white cloth hit man are you
supposed to be David Tyree bro Tyree to
come into into the pocket I believe my
love oh my god heat my mom would
complain these comics are filthy these
comics are filthy the few times she came
out here you know and I have six
brothers and three sisters so she's
heard filth you know like she's heard
some [ __ ] talk but she was like they're
all filthy and she was like that Brian
Holtzman was on just screaming and she
was like this is awful then I take her
in the original room and Dave Tyrese on
and he opens with I'm sorry I'm late we
were all sitting around licking my
neighbor's fingers he's Janet Jackson's
gynecologist and she's other [ __ ] oh
he's funny
he had a description of [ __ ] how like
when you're in your 20s it tastes like
peach cobbler
you know peach cobbler pie and then in
your 30s just starts to get a little
tangy and I forget the description he
would make but he goes in for tea to
taste like coffee and cigarettes and my
mother this [ __ ] is screamin over she
loved Dave hurry that was her favorite
cause I don't know why he's a pimp man
he slipped he did in there but yeah I
was thrilled the Eric Griffin and Andrew
they're all like store guys Andrew
Santino yeah yeah
magical yeah al magical Willie Barcena
and Freddie
Soto right before Freddie past they had
like a thing they were writing together
they were real close to selling it that
would have been a killer project
I love Willie Barcena come on Bros
everybody still for me bro everybody
stealin for me bro
if you is do it you say we're fighting
somebody yeah he was always in a fight
or doing a show I loved watching him
I don't know that is he wasn't come on
bro there 2012 - nice little bro yo tell
you bro he's one guy that'll get pissed
off if you get angry like I want you to
clubs when I'm like when I'm not
headlining I'm part of a big show like
last Thursday and I come in when I came
in with like three people and I'm the
girl at the cashier she try to charge me
to get in what right
what's up from the all things college I
know the Skyler Stone show oh okay think
of one to be honest woman I'm in the
show so oh sorry I'm sorry no it's cool
cool I don't know me either and then
social it again but I know comedian that
will freak out as something like that
yeah like I really would have freaked
out come on man you are a [ __ ] and then
Johnny Sanchez would be at the top of
that list too that's what I know by
watching him do that he broke me down me
I'm close without door for himself
yeah I mean he's a funny guy he's a
funny [ __ ] but it was yeah he
would fight with people a lot it was
constantly like so-and-so's taking my
[ __ ] this one's taking my [ __ ] um I did
when I first met him he was going to
court
cuz I'm somebody I guess he didn't like
the way he was introduced at the improv
and I'm I'm the way off how does this
get to the court that's what I want got
a microphone from here when you're
getting a microphone him Willie head
buds him and knocks him out baby
damn yeah it was armed with that guy's
of New York comic lives in Boca Raton
now I'll [ __ ] yeah and when I told a
story to another person that comedian
was a comedian that um he's Jewish and
on this this one
book called comedy road stories okay
Rick something wrote rich oh it's
probably rich Schneider rich lighter
right yeah yeah
he wrote it he's the guy that did our
like a bad anti-semitic joke even though
he's Jewish
I know on a cruise ship oh yes and a
helicopter bring his ass
I'm it scared him off yeah hilarious
I've seen a scene like or they'll send
up a boat hold on man Peter Fogelman
yeah so when I told him when I was
working with greg Giraldo my name
dropping but yeah when I told me I was
open for him and Jim pumpa the opener
and he told me now I know the guy goes
it was he was that he was like the name
you use when something went back to your
gig like you know like can kingpin I'm
done don't know where happened brother
Peter follow me broke what happened are
Peter foger at that game bro shut me
down you know I didn't know that but I
do remember it had the incident and that
he had to go to court
yeah I guess I forgot it was Peter I
blocked him out he was a lawyer here you
want a floor laying down and will you
keep performing knock around a knife or
mouth talk and of course Willie just
stepped over them and just use jokes
like nothing happened that's amazing at
least when the guy knocked out peanut
the back he just left
oh yeah peanut got knocked out here by
some with a Rando right or whatever some
do that it peanut owed money to or
something I just remember I had been
yelling at peanut as Darnell Valentine
my alter ego and then next thing you
know peanut gets knocked out people like
hey Darnell man that's one with peanut
I'm like what I walk out back and
they're like helping peanut up and then
somehow someone I think down bearson
someone was like well you know Rick
Ingram he was there the whole time
so then peanut kept calling me like hey
man I need you to come to court and
testify you saw this guy do it my ID I
wasn't there can you come testify anyway
I'm not testifying in court you cuz it
what are you talking about peanuts the
sweetest
just do a quick set for me
there was no dance no I need to get to
my destination if they're on the peanut
they're like I've got his visa on love
Deena through this I love when David
tell reference tone he's like you know
lots of people have comedy fathers you
know they say George Carlin inspired
them for me it's always been peanut it
was like that's so great the Dave Attell
their opinion on it and on the joke
wait till you you had a showcase six
times six weeks in a row I don't know
why I'm bringing back but that's a weird
thing III at times more well the three
minutes with me there she was there
yes she would come in 398 game is
driving give me three three three and
then ten and then yeah again okay cuz
she used a lot three three three three
three four five ten and then she said
Carly in four spots
oh I love it I was good cuz I was like
oh like I want to come back again but
that you like Oh Collin you're great I
called him a couple of times and but I
mean one of the time with I was like too
many too many big shots of course
because I remember like getting bombed
like like Tom Griffin oh yeah Eddie
Griffin went up and there for hours
before me
yeah yeah that's how you still are I
when I first showed up freeze love one
time he showed up nice and he said who's
next
and it was me on Filippa sorry and then
get the another two hours free love yeah
oh you don't have that privilege that's
amazing that he took it yeah he went
really long so that to watch his whole I
was funny oh he's amazing he was
hilarious you gotta be on me I'm Rican
oh here he a lot of people in here I
start pretty much time I stood when I
got bumped by dice or we all got bump I
just didn't watch the whole show with
like a free show yeah you don't know
like anywhere free hand fall off the
desk yeah he just kept getting drunker
and drunker and I was loving that dad
dented up NSX
yes oh my god it is not about that you
come in with a whole clan of people a
whole tribe of people so I shouldn't say
clammy you know any man no he's up there
like I remember he was up to Lake Manawa
say complaining but Yuri famous because
nobody's too popular
little man nobody to [ __ ] with me the
way in didn't [ __ ] with me my lord
didn't [ __ ] with me the only one who
[ __ ] was at ice man took me to do the
Madison Square Garden Show he took him
yeah I took him to Philadelphia I mean I
remember the story I try I'm trying to
get any young but he's in Vegas too all
the time but dice I will make it in for
that also
well dice uh yeah because these guys had
to deal with a long a different level he
didn't break my balls as much but he
kind of respected me because I was
Missy's assistant so I had a little bit
of a yeah I just I can't deal someone
who is a compulsive liar completely
polish you and I'd be like he'd lie to
my face I'm like dude I was there that
didn't happen like but I just let it go
because it was Eddie he was just he
would just talk [ __ ] but he died took
him to Philadelphia and he was like pack
we're going tomorrow whatever so Eddie
was like okay and he's like young knew
he came Andrew said he had like like
maybe a brown paper bag and he was like
where's your luggage and he's like this
is it like a toothbrush deodorant and so
that was real close that one who wasn't
living in his car I think so that they
were going to Philadelphia and it was
[ __ ] freezin Andrew had to take them
to get clothes like so they went
shopping the first day in Philadelphia
on South Street
that's how he had to open he had no
clothes for it like he was just going to
wear his shorts and his t-shirt he'd
have a jacket you know [ __ ] I saw some
interview someone posted online maybe
like five or six months ago vedi talking
he's talking about opening for dice and
how he crushed so hard that dice had a
hard time following him and then he's
going well now he's like that yeah I'm
his son's oldest son's Godfather a lot
of people don't know that Godfather
I know Jewish people had Godfather so ah
I saw maxum on maxum a Godfather he's
like what are you talking I just wanted
out for that movie know what it is I was
[ __ ] mine what so when you got past
did you get spots on the tire you how
long did you work here I went for last
two weeks
yeah I couldn't lamb I couldn't do that
ladder Oh
wobbly you know too fat you're just
human yeah and then like chewy right
that is a big Mexican dude for the wood
job going on
Chuy Castro oh I know it's tough April
April of Yui so you're holding a letter
for me still shaking it thanks Marcy we
don't hooked up yeah I'll come back
tomorrow man
[ __ ] in that the weight thing is always
persisted because I was so skinny that
no matter what where I was working it
always came you're gonna have to change
the side of that why too fast I started
hating to medium with long names doing
that oh yeah like I will do the name of
these [ __ ] I can't say that I
get a [ __ ] nickname man yes Missy
would give people nicknames at the Neo
campy he's gone camping yeah John Kappa
realistic home campy just like camping
he'd be like who's [ __ ] can't be sad
baby
neither of doggin Guido's that baby was
Jojo yes she called her a bad baby
yeah on night of a thousand Guido's was
an awful show that we have choose to
make me put the [ __ ] Italian you know
like those records
yeah like put it on every table in the
main room you know what that is me I'd
have Freddy Soto Cory would help because
Cory was a talent his wife is a town
coordinator at the time so we would put
all those on every day every time we had
this stupid night of a thousand Guido's
I remember um she was trying to do our
Latino night show that the one and um oh
hi Wyatt La Jolla oh yeah and then
Marilyn did it me a Maryland robe and
I'm Gary Glitter drove together we get
there the sign said taco - yeah the one
is only three Mexican performing yes it
was us and I'm Frank Manzano from
Santiago
just the other day she was out there
that guy Wow yeah I forgot existed
I took over the Alamo that gift shop
will never be the same [ __ ] do
it that we have some weird characters
everyone I thought that we were gonna
kill this guy like with comedy like I
thought you know we're gonna just blow
him up the water yeah we thought you
know we were gone
yeah cocky we just doing the
[ __ ] I kill this guy we didn't
know anything had a long set you know we
had paid ten million to to do it
this guy just stood up there for 45
minutes just doing one line or two
one-liner quick like that fortunately
they were scared in here who the [ __ ] is
this guy by twenty ten minutes fifteen
minutes and they were loving him loved
it
I remember that guy Taco Tuesday he
taught him how to tip before I never
tipped anywhere I mean no we're we're
saying I mean when I was doing without
doing open mic at the natural budge that
just angered me but yeah she the way
shift came up to my table Azam you know
you guys got a tip right but bringing
you guys nachos food you guys giving me
a dime and then you want to dine I don't
know you know I've never you never done
but you never worked in the food
industry where I never been to a
restaurant with all my food been fast
food my food had never been brought to
me in my life of the riding one to reach
the brothers Chinese food in the Jolla
and then well I got up to leave as well
he goes hey what you guys are doing
we're done eating bro the [ __ ] whatever
they're to do you guys leave a tip ah
come on
it was no man you're gonna stop breaking
you're gonna you're gonna kind of break
the stereotype man they say Mexicans
don't tip you're going to start tipping
so ever since then with the attendant I
would say I wouldn't say Mexicans don't
tip I would say foreigners didn't tip
like that really didn't yeah it didn't
in their country yes Pacific I like that
it wasn't on there there's no normal
European Europe they do include it it's
included right yeah a lot of pay their
people more so a lot of what we didn't
know yeah so that like that I always I
always give people the benefit of the
doubt but waiting tables so long
when I go to a restaurant I mean I tip
like crazy I'm terrible I tip like I'm
going to go back to waiting tables
tomorrow I always I worked at Chili's
down in torrents and our clientele was
mostly black people and I always thought
Aereo type that exists yeah I feel like
they got the Reformation just from not
from not tipping me ever I mean I had
like a party of like 12 and they would
leave me like whatever the change was
left over from the biack 185 dollars and
60 cents and I get back there just
before you work harder with that see any
other team yeah come on man with my
water yeah I thought it was always it
was always white boy that was always my
oh yeah white boy gets more strawberry
lemonade damn it oh no the main room we
had Fat Tuesday dude call me Suzy
chapstick I'm like that's gonna stop a
South Philly off like this whole [ __ ]
room don't get me crazy and then I would
like you know one-up them and then they
would chill and then I became their
favorite and one of my regulars was
Warren G that was my boyfriend yeah you
would over tip right he's a regular
person yeah that was my boy over tip me
right and one time he has is like
entourage with girls with him and this
was on Fat Tuesday was in the belly room
right so I would take care of all make
sure he had a seat because you could
barely get in there that we had to move
it to the main room because it was
jam-packed so I get him a seat make sure
he was taken care of you know get him
his drinks and he gave me like a $60 tip
and as I was walking away like Lauren G
took care of me but he bought all these
drinks right so I was about to walk down
the back steps and the girl as I excuse
me come here for a second I was like
yeah she's like um yeah he's saying he
want his change back I'm like whoo she's
like Warren we're wet Warren and they
all looked at me and they were like yeah
we're one so I was like okay so I gave
her the 50 bucks back and then I pulled
him aside I go ahead did you want me to
give those girls 50 bucks he goes what
girls and like what those guy he went
over he's [ __ ] regulated
yeah handle your way me a hundred yeah
that was my boy I was like [ __ ] well
she got $50 worth of beatin that was
trying to take money I like me Lord I
will fight all for you give a [ __ ] I
would have thrown gonorrhea all over it
was so it was so like hot and sticky in
that [ __ ] belly room that's why I
waited for YCJA
and then I went back and asked him but
it was like I wanted to get him to the
side you don't I mean because you
disrupt the show in the belly room if
you talk to anybody like the island that
shows the guy Torry showed for Fat
Tuesday more like the audience wanna be
famous too oh my god like really a big
show for them okay I got a roll out
I got your hot spot shut up yeah Ricky
will close it up how long we been on
here no all right have a good set man
Felipe we'll wrap it up Thank You Danny
do you remember Danny yeah yeah that's
right
I don't remember him for hanging I was
Freddy a lot yeah yeah Freddy yeah I
keep him in my pocket every night so we
perform every night together you have
him up there - yeah this is getting beat
up man I gotta get a new hole
I saw been in here forever I went to
overall Street ah for Dale the dead oh
yeah sorry other dead um November 1st
yeah it was the other dead there and I
saw Prince Cory there princess Cory yeah
yeah oh yeah that was right after him
and them oh my god I remember that and
she bought a statue I was furious with
her yeah
spent like 350 on Laurie but she was
still in Chennai daily dead and they
were like because I I guess I'm the bad
daddy
and when you're like Catholic and you're
yeah yeah especially Latino you got to
put a photo of the dead person you love
with candles and his favorite food or
whatever it is and she had her own she
had made her own little her own little
warm I don't know what they call it when
someone dies and you put candles yeah
yeah like a not a seance but like a
little memorial yeah maybe she had a
memorial for Freddy at the overall
Street
she was there all day with our crews yes
crews will be 15 ms months and she still
has his but at that time she still had
his phone yeah because it was he died
July 10th and yeah she went I was
yelling at her for going to that she's
like I'm going I'm like okay fine go you
know but she say there all day okay I
remember and I didn't know about the
food thing but Freddie favored food with
Turkey I don't know why but he would be
like damn I'm miss turkey I'm like oh
you know that you could get Turkey
anywhere because now you can only you
know none thanks like Thanksgiving and
Christmas that was a [ __ ] so but yeah I
remember she went and his family was
here his mom and dad were here and they
didn't even go because they were too
remorse you know not not doing well with
it so mm-hmm
yeah she's [ __ ] naughty butters but
she bought that too statue for like
three hundred fifty dollars on the
quarry [ __ ] broke you know we're
trying to raise money cuz dice and
capper ill oh and I think Rick went and
I Steve Simone Steve Rannazzisi who else
went Ralphie May maybe they did a big
benefit in El Paso
it was dices first time in El Paso and
if they went and they got like they
raised like honor thousand dollars right
yeah and I was a lot and then they put
it in like funds and ship for cruise so
that like you know Cory Cory is figuring
out like so cruise doesn't have to worry
about school but luckily they live over
like Eagle Rock so they went to some
good schools cruise goes to some cool
schools and how does she know she's
gonna be fifteen this month that's crazy
right yeah how is she Corey oh she's
finally 44 no how is she doing oh how is
she I thought how old is she I was like
when I just said Cory's age she'll kill
me
she's so beat me up with a tiara she's
good Jesus I mean I I don't talk to her
as much as I used to because as I said I
started doing comedy and I travel so
much and but I try to text with them as
much as possible but the last time I
talked to her she was good you know she
still involved with cruise and she does
fashion stuff so that helps you know I
mean she makes good money renting out
costumes and [ __ ] like all that [ __ ]
Freddie
to break her balls for by him he rents
it out now and she makes decent money
not not killer but like you know she
does okay
I think but right now Cruz is with his
family in El Paso so that's good because
she gets to go his father passed away
right his father passed away four years
after Freddie died on Freddie's birthday
I'll [ __ ] where did that he he got to
see me do stand-up in the belly room and
at this point you had that voice box
because he had a cancer bath yeah so he
has a voice box and he was a egg like he
could barely speak and I was like
[ __ ] bawling you know cuz I'm like no
mr. Soto like we were all so close and
when he would come visit that was my
favorite like we would laugh for hours
man
regardless regardless regardless Johnny
Sanchez was like you're going to give
yourself an aneurysm so I can perform
into eight people as your dad getting so
crazy because he would get so animated I
don't know when the day after the
Freddie passed like there was so many
people at the store fine and I passed by
and I wanted I wanted to hang out -
mm-hmm but I had just fallen off the
wagon and they when I looked over I saw
Johnny Sanchez in a tank top kind of
buzz regulating neck see this looks like
trouble if I stay here because if Johnny
starts something I'm have to help him
and yeah it just kept going away home
how long have you been sober
um alright out drinking and um I stopped
drinking
in 2009 drugs all that stuff but it was
more weed okay but I stopped in 2009 I
stopped doing coke and I felt like we
actually caught it on Hill oh wow you
were there that is luck yeah xanax is a
big one I took one once my ex used to
have the little football things is that
the xanax
yeah you cut it in pieces yeah yeah so I
took one maybe a little piece or
something
and he was like yeah you got to chill
out so take this you know this will help
and I'm like I don't do drugs you know I
never I don't even like to swallow Advil
like I'm afraid of [ __ ] like that and it
hurts my stomach so I was like
I was so stressed out I was like I'm
gonna take it I slept for 16 hours
whoa I'm like the worst drug addict but
the best if you want to roofie me
because I'll be out for like a while I
don't feel [ __ ] so have at it
I'm kidding text email but no it was
like he was like [ __ ] and then I did
Australia with dice we went for a month
over there and that's a 15 hour flight
so I was like hey give me one of those
things they had to wake me up when we
landed I slept the whole way they're all
[ __ ] get up oh my gosh it was all
groggy for what two days but that's the
only time I ever took it those two times
I I can see how people get addicted
though yeah
the other time I did signings was when I
was doing coke like I would do like two
bombs at level it yeah I didn't know 11
it some guy just gave it to me it was
brought to that after a while chicken to
the titties annex then after realize
okay dumb the Daleks is keeping me alive
right now then ah interesting way to
look at it I think you're right because
yeah that's it it was like mellow mellow
yeah was annex alone but it woulda
killed me too so the coke was keeping me
from diving Daleks and the zani will
keep me from dive on coke that's insane
would you like people always play with a
pebble pox ever heard of that one shake
hands with getting a little out much I
can't believe Joey silver like I love
that Joey's clean like I'm all out
here's I knew Joey he was looking for a
way to get what do you mean yeah well
they were about to drop a dare it was
about Terry the Martell cartel oh my god
call Padres
all come to the morale chief all those
[ __ ] like let's go to Elphaba
grab like ready hey tell Capano what's
going on and I'll come over here I
thought I was going to put cheer by
really like I'm the only one that's
eating here here we go just order your
Mexican Grill to go right back we right
bags I'm with the bathroom is going to a
bathroom the one eating chips and really
nobody eats here no
me and Cory are you or the only ones
eating
we're like isn't that great I don't know
why he likes to come your food out that
girl tell me not to be top layer yes you
give her 20 she played a little song a
little bad comes out when I was 40 I
like when he joined in know that I was
doing like a lot of blow at the same
time that he was doing blow so I was
hanging out with him one night and I
thought that I'm we're both going to
score right so he goes to buy his [ __ ]
and eat them and him I want to buy some
too hope I didn't speak up all quiet so
we got our compadre so do you think a
bag out of nowhere he opened it up put
some straw inside and does a whole
[ __ ] a whole 20 bags ah goes by a
burrito across the street and eats it
right after I guess there was no sadness
I guess oh yeah he used the burrito
fooling that good he could order a
burrito at home poverty he was across
the street on a truck
holy who's not blown into burrito I I
have a friend he would do blow and he go
to sleep I'm like what off [ __ ] you're
doing it wrong like that's not what I
supposed to all my friends I hung out
with always did it I was always around
it but I never tried it I never I never
even smoke weed but I think I'm like a
addict like I smoked the cigarette when
I was 9 and took me 21 years to quit and
then I did like ice-t I'm addicted
totally [ __ ] addicted like if I don't
have it I'll [ __ ] kill somebody
unsweetened or sweetened sweetened
naturally lemon tea or southern tea
lemon see I don't know there was
southern teacher I saw that she was
sweet it's that's a little I got it I
work in Kansas City I was working at
Stanford and sons I know I've been there
oh yeah it's a great place they took me
to this little spot this little barbecue
spot on the Missouri side and I got I
was like I'm gonna get a sweet team
because I love T so much but that was
that was like the whole bag of sugar in
a cup and then some tea
I was like flock like and I drank it too
because I don't give a [ __ ] but I was
like oh this is [ __ ] my tongue was
swollen like this is that and then the
barbecue was okay so you had Lenny
places
yeah headlining ass whuppin name of the
owner uh Craig Craig [ __ ] is his last
name he's so funny he's got some story
everywhere look no he wrote a book it
was optioned for a movie like he's
trying to sell it it has those paper
clippings of him being a vigilante a
vigilante that was robbing regulators
yeah a nice book though he would tell
you that when he went to court that all
those so based on uh subpoena all those
comedians no no he went to court when he
would I call it mean comedians that work
for him yeah he went to court and he
said that a lot of names but it started
popping up you know like I guess they
were trying to get him in I don't know
that he was they came up because to say
that he was doing bad or to help his
case that he was they did a good guy oh
I see I mean like I help this comic
discover yeah yeah no I remember I can't
think of as I think Rick that was Rick's
home club so he does him a lot he does a
great impression of him and there's
three brothers one of them was killed in
a car accident about five years ago
four or five years ago so everything
went to [ __ ] they have moved the club
now it's in the middle of this big mall
it's not like in the prime spot where it
was before they Club in the bottom right
not anymore
that was that was a the exciting one I
can't think at the where they called it
they called it something I can't
remember but he said it was there for a
long time and that's when it was bumping
it was really hot I'm around Chris Reed
from Karen played the secular and even
african-american right but instead that
Club the club downstairs old man bro it
turned into a Ludacris concert on there
yeah he used to have all those guys he
said he ran a black Club he goes in he
hacked he's no hat salado
yeah no hats no jerseys yep that's how
they think they regulate that guy tour
you step
do that here on Fat Tuesday you see they
use the footage you know implement a
dress code so that he could eliminate
certain aspects he thought I don't like
there was still shooting hey nothin
could now we have well-dressed dogs in
here
sure yeah they're just covering up their
tattoos with lemon yeah I got a lemon
button-up shirt and everything you know
you could still see they're still fight
and it was still some some fights we
only have one shootout with guy um and
that was to pasta people you see I
remember um um I was walking and I saw
somebody told me that louis farrakhan
son was there oh and a store door Fat
Tuesday Laura and then he came in a
Ferrari a red Ferrari and I remember
like his bodyguards they're called fruit
of Islam yeah they're the ones that
killed Malcolm X good of Islam his
bodyguard showed early there was six
foot five bodyguards and they stopped
sunset from moving so Farrakhan story
can get out that's it like they treat
him like a political figure that those
guys came out and stopped both traffic
and they are they waited for the caravan
to go out and in the Ferrari after them
they're not a bodyguard drove all that
he would like the President of the
United States you know [ __ ] Ferrari
like that's the part that's angering me
more than stopping the traffic is those
people were supposed to be like for you
know we're all equal this is the
internet saying like religious right
aren't they yeah Muslim Muslim and I'm
thinking um wow man that's a lot of
[ __ ] bean pies a bunch sold a lot of
papers for this fool to have a Ferrari
you ready because I'm saying he's
feeling the be that was supposed to be
like kind of humbled living regular
people is what the few I've spoken to
yeah that's Rory could have given to
serve a lot of breakfast for inner-city
kids
oh yeah it's like the Vatican I always
get mad at the bad again because it's
such a big you know and there's no
many it's so expensive to keep the
upkeep I mean I get it it's beautiful
and there's churches but it can be kind
of taken their own government huh oh god
yeah I know I read on a paper I hate her
yeah I read on the internet that they
stopped accepting cash at the Vatican
because someone so much counterfeit so
everything is card now they're ATMs
well nothing they can track it better so
yeah everything has to be like that
there's so many places that don't accept
cash I wish we did that during Fat
Tuesday every every other Tuesday I
would have like a hundred dollars in
fake five I'm like what the [ __ ] who's
doing five god damn it
yeah I'm checking hunter fountains
happening and I'm you know all the girls
were [ __ ] because it was like somebody
was doing sighs for a while and it still
didn't tip well with fires oh no it was
it'll be modified if I've covered the
drink see people understand man when you
and always talk about it in my act when
you have fake fives fake 20s don't use
that on waitresses
that's a waste man those those girls
work hard you wanna get rid of big five
which was strip bar sometimes where car
tissue dance initiative $5 tuna turning
into a peso oh good have you done the
other podcast I feel like yeah it would
be ridiculous I'd better I've done
Joey's a couple times but I feel like
you two would just I do though the wild
Dodie la you know what kata yai Rodrigo
Torres my co-pilot on the podcast he
does a comm Juliet I'm tired bro oh I
love that Jojo D&L yeah he does a good
man mellow Jovi and I could do the
louder the guy was a [ __ ] you know what
about if I [ __ ] see Kat right now
hungover [ __ ]
but he doesn't aim well you know bra
okay so funny is 1975 bro 1975 you know
yeah I can do com1 he does a good com1
he I know bro and my brother Tommy he
listens to the
my podcast he listens to a lot of like
stuff with comics and he's like hey who
is that guy he's like I think he's
Mexican and is a white of him to say I
think he's Mexican but he's a drug
addict he's from Jersey and I'm like I
have no idea talking about right and I'm
just like Mexican gigantic Jersey and
then Joe Diaz told me I know he's from
Jersey but he just think of him as New
York like cuz he's from Newark like he's
um not Newark a good North Bergen
but it's up its north his way close it's
ten minutes outside of Manhattan so I'm
like wait what
and then I realized oh [ __ ] it's Joe
Diaz he's not a drug dealer
he's Cuban and I mean he's not a drug
addict anymore whatever but yes I
returned it but every time he calls the
radio station my brother hears and he
tells these old crazy stories of [ __ ]
- and junk so Tommy please still a drug
I I mean no no no no he's sober he's
crazy but he's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah he's Cuban right yeah I love Joe
dance we did silly together a feature
for him so it was just me and him so
it's like a cold kind of open nobody
like I just go out 2:30 and then he just
went out and killed my friends love to
him they were like oh [ __ ] this guy's
great like I had a lot of people come to
see me and then they were like oh
because usually I went down my rera and
then like a South Philly guy they know
what to expect but Joe Diaz they were
like what the [ __ ] was that
we loved that my brother Billy was
trying to get him to go out and party
I'm like no no he's staying here calm
down
anyway thank you so much very badly
yeah so are you gonna love working with
you here like I love that you vent we
did that also me and man owed him that
thank you man so much fun I have to
perform for Freddie kinda looks like
you're like I'm helping him keep it out
there if you will but yeah I love doing
stand-up it's ten years I've been doing
it over ten years now so I thought you
were doing for a long time
you'll be kidding it I caught things
I've been doing it forever
no just uh I mean when I'm lucky because
I get to go out with dice on the road a
lot
and sometimes it pays to sleep around so
but he takes me everywhere and his
crowds are the hardest so I feel like I
got a crazy bootcamp coming in yeah and
so it was like kill or be killed and I
just kept the state up you know I didn't
get killed I run it that's good man
that's good you're doing well you are
funny
thank you I appreciate that means a lot
coming from you you and Rick killed on
that show
I love the quote I like I like his crowd
work oh yeah killing it and then you
went up and like could usually like it's
been awhile you know like when you see
like a lot of you see like oh is she
gonna kill but yeah you killed I knew
you were gonna kill but I had to see it
myself
yeah that was a good crowd too though
and I love that the podcast does that
like the all things comedy does that I
think it's a monthly show where they
just have different people that have a
podcast on their network come in and
they all do Santa like bill burr I think
the first time he did it and the first
time they did it and they called me they
were like hey you want to be on the show
it's all things and Bill's going to be
on it and I was like [ __ ] the only out
goal I was working on the Kid Rock
cruise and so I was like [ __ ] I'm doing
I'm working I'm thinking I can't cancel
my Kid Rock crew is just there to work
with bill Berg but I was so excited that
he was going to be on it but then when
they did it we got to do it was all us
so it was good it was like Ari Shaffir
is a comedy sir guy forever and ever and
I love that his thing is on all things
comedy and there's a lot of comments or
podcasts on what network we're on all
things how can probably awesome yeah
that's why we're all cool you know every
time they call and change up the people
because there's so many you guys are on
all things yes we wish we film every
Wednesday Wednesday what's the name
year's what's our full podcast this week
we have a meta med Oh Aleta America I'm
aware mobile app Aleta
he will come in as Ellis a Ameri made a
mobile a colita why does everybody sing
to him I always think to is ha ha ha did
no one Rock Me Amadeus
gosh we have my mama is I always think
I'm mad I love him
I met him as great so you have every
week every Wednesday yours comes out
okay
ours is Thursday I think we have Natasha
Leggero last week we had a last week -
oh my god that's awesome yes Shayna
promote their holy mall yeah so that's
cool yeah and Natasha plays dices
girlfriend on his show Oh so yes I love
it was promoting dice too technically
because it starts 8 xx xx the show comes
out I saw dice briefly in Miami when you
were doing the Miami improv okay before
they closed me and Rodrigo we got
through the night the day before so we
wouldn't go check him out and man who is
over was it Rick it was some some white
dude I don't know oh that's what who's
from Florida think I don't know it name
oh okay I could have been one of the
Ernst brothers not Brett the other one
Keith I don't know yeah we'd and then
how long ago oh man it was like for you
four years ago three okay I could have
been Florentine to jim Florentine and
you went up there man it was a packed
show because he did on Miami one night
against would like oh he's off night so
he had it off he Oded him himself then
after that he went to Fort Lauderdale
yeah yeah the Hard Rock's legit did
one-nighter man it was awesome you know
it was it was like I never seen him
perform here but just trying out stuff
yes I never seen a full size man set and
I remember man my I'm getting my goose
boats talking about it cause it was
exciting man and when when you tell him
he better from guy on stage he couldn't
get laid with that [ __ ] sweater that
[ __ ] sweater says keep off [ __ ]
whatever I keep making funny guy on
stage and then when he got to the
nursery rhymes the whole [ __ ] place
tore up and I was like a [ __ ] kid
again right yeah you know Hickory hey
whatever right anyway we were all doing
it man
I tweeted the next day man because if
you can ever see the times my lady
[ __ ] you guys the best show I've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life
it was like at a [ __ ] summer camp
with a bunch of [ __ ] drunk at a toast
good and when they get into those rhymes
they're like kids again yeah they're
like hickory dickory dock I mean they
verbatim verbatim you turns into
groupies again yeah we're waiting we're
backstage I was looking for him tonight
get a handshake those are gonna come out
right now man he's gonna get a towel oh
oh yeah yeah oh you want to came out
knowing every comment aman gentleman I
would say he hit hit hit an awesome
skateboard we'll talk to him next time
that yeah anytime you would love you
that's it anytime young comics coming
gets excited you know like hey oh that's
awesome you like me it felt like
somebody is used to being like people
that you [ __ ] bump to me man you
bumped me for an hour you know people
yell out of it I love that you took it
like oh I get a free shelf I'm gonna
plead I smash for the Fieri Griffin Show
yeah well there's something here and you
did man cause you're [ __ ] hilarious I
just waited waited if so fun always been
funny
thank you yeah so I'm glad I'm thrilled
that you came and did this thank you so
much what's your social media oh my
Felipe's world.com FPL IP es wor d world
Teresa's world com1 saw food podcast I
have a HBO special coming out number 30
ibi Wyatt okay we sold it to them your
body yes Claude right yeah yeah yeah
good guy by the way great thing the good
is a good guy a good guy I'm excited
about that
you said it looks great you do great I'm
really so it's called I'll translate
this stuck and check that out if you
guys love that alright thank you so much
Eleonora Rick Ingram yes
I can't do a Ric impression so request a
right guy and Rick's up there [ __ ] on
people in the main room so thanks for
listening in to living in fool thank you
[Music]
[Applause]